you are going to see flames that fly
without pilots we're a little scary
about change because it's the unknown
civil libertarians frankly have a right
to be concerned about price the new
pilotless plane the drum when you hear
the word drone you may immediately think
of bombs being dropped in the Middle
East or the surveillance of citizens
here in the United States but aviation
geeks and engineers have wondered for
decades if unmanned flight might solve a
few of our world's problems or make our
lives a little easier for the last 50
years science magazines marveled over
drones sniffing out pollution taking
photos from the air or making pilots
obsolete
there she goes
the new pilotless plane the drone you
may not know it but the military used
drones decades ago here is a closer look
at this amazing reconnaissance robot
recently tested at Fort Huachuca called
the drone it is designed to carry
photographic equipment or a TV camera
drones like this one paved the way for
the new Albion questionable world of
robotic warfare in the Middle East now
unmanned aerial system technology is a
regular part of the military's
day-to-day operations unmanned aircraft
have been the technology that's been
evolving and there's been quite a lot of
attention really throughout the whole
history of aviation John Villasenor is a
professor of Electrical Engineering and
public policy at UCLA and a senior
fellow at the Brookings Institution what
has changed in the last what's called
decade or so is that the combination of
advances in electronics and of course
the availability of the GPS system and
advances in airframe design and flight
control methods and things like that
I've made it very possible to build very
inexpensive unmanned aircraft and
thereby to make them with an easy reach
of pretty much anybody who wants them so
the technology has now reached the point
where it can be very inexpensive to buy
one I bought this drone on amazon.com
and even though I can't fly high into
the atmosphere it demonstrates the
availability Villasenor talks about
we think that the unmanned vehicles are
coming into civilian years so they're
going to be a tremendous benefit to
civilian society I think this is not
only the coming industry it's already
here this is a symposium at a hotel in
Thousand Oaks California it's just one
of the many public discussions happening
right now across the United States about
drones the potential of UAVs benefit
mankind in firefighting and agriculture
pollution stopping all kinds of loss of
life because we were able to send a
remote vehicle instead of the human life
into that is amazing there's
applications for moviemaking for real
estate for inspecting the roof of a very
large factory structure agricultural
monitoring fisheries monitoring severe
weather monitoring
hydrology and water management there's a
lot of things that you can do these
vehicles meet Sandra Magnus she's the
executive director of the American
Institute of Aeronautics and
Astronautics and are you ready for this
a former astronaut but in order to use
them appropriately you have to figure
out how to integrate them into the
National Airspace you also have to
figure out how you're going to operate
and what your policy should be so today
we have in the symposium representatives
from the policy world the sensor world
the consumer world the people who have
experience already using these unmanned
systems and so it's a way to have a
dialogue across the whole community to
make sure we're thinking of all the
right things and moving in the right
direction together as a part of the
Federal Aviation Administration's
reauthorization of funds in February
2012 Congress passed a bill that
included the integration of unmanned
aircraft into US airspace by 2015 first
Republic entities like law enforcement
or firefighters and second for civilians
like farmers or filmmakers giving some
companies the confidence to hit the
ground running this is one of the drone
dudes and he's giving this drone one
last check up before it takes flight in
downtown Los Angeles drone dudes is a
two year old company of young filmmakers
and engineers who specialized in
low-level aerial filmmaking they're a
small operation but have found a steady
business shooting sporting events across
the United States today
they're shooting skateboarders skating
down the sixth Street bridge
while the idea of flying robots with
cameras hovering above the earth might
make you a little uneasy drone
enthusiasts think companies like drone
dudes could be the future of drone
technology in America so we think it's
kind of the next great thing like the
internet and
and the wireless technology and the
interconnectivity we all have now with
our smart devices but it's not as if you
can't miss use those technologies
unmanned aircraft are like many other
technologies and they happen in the
sense that they have many beneficial
applications but they can also be
misused and of course we see that with
mobile phones we see them in the
Internet
we've seen that cameras roll camera roll
film first became inexpensive and easy
to get in the late 1800s there was quite
a lot of concern about the privacy
implications of photography human beams
I think are very natures we're a little
scary about change because it's the
unknown but we're explorers too and so
we're constantly balancing that tension
between what's the unknown like and then
part of us gearing to go into the
unknown and this is all the debate you
hear about the use of unmanned vehicles
on both sides you're seeing that tension
played out well I think civil
libertarians frankly have a right to be
concerned about privacy I think I think
there are privacy concerns I think it's
a deny that a manned aircraft raised you
know raised will will in some cases be
used in a manner that violates privacy
that that wouldn't yeah that would be
overly naive it will happen if a
government operator from an aircraft
violates the Fourth Amendment then
obviously then that's unconstitutional
and
that would be a problem and then for
non-government operators there are
invasion of privacy statutes so for
example if someone would have taken
unmanned aircraft and fly it just
outside your second-floor window and you
know take photographs into the interiors
or home that's you know really if it was
done without permission it's clearly an
invasion of privacy I also think it's
important for people with an interest in
civil liberties and everyone else to
look at it on the other side has
operators of unmanned aircraft because
we have we have all of us an affirmative
First Amendment right to gather
information so unmanned aircraft in the
hands of people who are gathering
information which include people in the
news media and others can be a very
powerful tool is just like cameras are
today obviously provided that they're
used you know with respect for people's
privacy and so on technology is a tool
and you have to be mindful how you use
it but we can't let our fear keep us
from reaping the benefits of our brains
which is where the technology comes from
while most drone use has been limited to
police and other state agencies the FAA
recently approved two drones for
civilian use which could fly as early as
2013 for recent TV
I'm Paul Detrick